plaisir stoppe l'hémorragie après cinq
défaites consécutives dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 les plaisirs
en russie a dominé avec la manière le
paris université club à domicile
le score est sans appel à 28 à 8 on sait
que bah il nous faut absolument une
victoire il nous la fallait absolument
et je crois que tout le monde avait à
coeur de bien faire les choses et
défensivement on a su les agresser et
voilà quand on avait tous envie de bien
faire les choses et
voilà ça c'est vu ça s'est senti
solitaire en tout cas avec cette
victoire plaisir quitte la place de
lanterne rouge et remonte à l'avant
dernière place du championnat à
seulement un petit point du maintien
on est dans une poule qui est très
compliqué nous on est encore tout jeune
à ce niveau-là et du cou et du coup ça
demande beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
beaucoup de sacrifice d'abnégation et
voilà et tout le boulot qu'on met en
place depuis la saison depuis le début
de saison
il commence à payer et je crois que
c'est ça qui fait vraiment plaisir on
progresse dans le jeu et dans
l'intensité la semaine dernière à drancy
on doit gagner là bas et aujourd'hui on
a réussi à garder le même niveau de jeu
la même intensité
prochain match pour plaisir le 11
novembre sur le terrain de chartres les
cinquièmes du classement
une nouvelle victoire pourrait
définitivement lancé la saison des
plaisirs war